by the way I got a compliment I mean
you're wearing a heavy coat but uh
you've lost a shitload of weight not on
OIC you did it the oldfashioned way
right you got your [__] together and
what' you do cuz you look good thank you
sir yeah well I mean the first step was
I remember I went on on tour and I was
like you know what I'm going to
eat I'm going to eat grilled
chicken I'm going to eat
carrots and I'm going to have a little
bit of white rice every night with
buffalo sauce or not buffalo sauce hot
sauce has no calories in it isn't that a
miracle blown away I was like wait what
the [__] is actually going on hot sauce
has no calories in it this is [__] is
sick I get it something good that
doesn't have calories yeah I I know I
was like what the hell's going on
and so I I I remember on tour I stopped
eating a lot of fried stuff a lot of
pizza all that stuff because usually at
the end of the
day after a show you're done you finish
up around
2:00 you don't really know what city
you're in you don't really know where
you are you're just in the bus so it's
like what's really open and it's always
like you know greasy stuff and so I was
like okay let's do let's try to just do
this and I lost 20 pounds doing that and
I was like let's keep going let's keep
building
and we just kept [__] rocking and
rolling